so you may remember in the Deep recesses
of your brain that creepy shop teacher
in Canada who decided to sexualize the
kids in his shop class getting him
involved in his weird fetish life
the guy uses the name Kayla Lemieux and
then shows up to class at Oakville
Trafalgar School wearing gigantic
prosthetic breasts apparently emulating
a style of Japanese pornography called
exploding Milk porn not making this up I
wish we were the Halton District School
Board and the oak filter Fowler School
have defended this guy now finally some
parents are considering legal action
Rishi Bend who is with the Bandu Law
Firm he's also a parent of a sixth a
ninth grader rather at Oakville he joins
us to explain we sure appreciate your
coming on tonight
um and thank you for having The Bravery
to make your position public what what
is your position about this shop teacher
well thanks for having me Tucker we
really appreciate your interest in this
well what we've done is we've asked the
board essentially to do three things
number one is we've asked them to apply
the student dress code to the teachers
because one doesn't exist for the
teachers
and in our view it's just illogical and
absurd to suggest that that the teachers
would be held to a lower standard than
the than the students in terms of of
their attire
secondly once we've established what
that standard is if the the school board
is creating exceptions from that
standard we want to know specif
specifically what those exceptions are
and then thirdly we would like the
school board to cease and desist from
interfering with the right of the
parents to discuss this matter and
they've repeatedly done that in uh in
school council meetings since the
beginning of the year
it just what this reveals is their
priorities and they seem much more
concerned with protecting and affirming
this guy's personal sexual Journey than
they are with your kids and it's a
school shouldn't they be primarily
concerned with the kids who go to the
school
well I I do agree with that and look
this is an issue about gender identity
and expression in in human rights by
their nature are complex but but gender
identity and expression are relatively
new grounds that have been introduced
into the Ontario's code in in 2012 so we
don't have a lot of jurisprudence or
direction from that from our tribunal or
or the courts
um and so I think what the board is
doing is they've taken an overly
risk-averse approach to this issue and
look I can understand and appreciate
that they have a diversity and inclusion
mandate and as a racialized person with
racialized children in this in in in
those schools I commend that approach
and I and I appreciate that however what
they're missing is that is that when it
comes to Human Rights and particularly
gender identity and expression context
is important and there's a very delicate
balancing of interest that have to
happen here and I don't think that
they've done that appropriately and and
as you've pointed out Tucker I think the
context that they're missing here is
that this is a school and these are
children and they're adolescents and
their their maturity is still is still
developing now on the other hand I think
I think there's some extreme views taken
to this as well which say that
transgendered individuals don't have any
rights on the law and the problem is is
that is that that's an extreme View and
and and the the parents that I represent
and the parents that support them are
being labeled as discriminatory or or
bigoted
and that's the problem it polarizes us
and what we need is is a constructive
approach some constructive dialogue and
some common sense on this issue
well you're not going to get
constructive dialogue if no dialogue is
allowed if parents aren't allowed to
talk so I hope at the very least you win
that battle and get freedom of speech
back I think that's a prerequisite
um I'm hopeful that we will amen
appreciate you having me thank you
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight